rivers of blood like all katanas it
hails from the land of reeds a far away
place that has long been locked in a
violent Civil War greatest of all its
Warriors was a demon of a swordsman
named okina okina naturally attracted a
cult of followers the white Reeds who
fight in a white Garb that symbolizes a
very Japanese preparedness for death but
okina would eventually abandon even
these Avid followers rising to a higher
plane where there was only himself his
Katana and its Mastery in one battle
okina landed a strike against Moog the
Lord of blood and as Moog marveled at
okina's sword upon his flesh he counted
with a proposal offering okina a life
where his Bloodshed would never go
unsated so it is that okina now invades
endlessly as a bloody finger but his
head disciples continued to pursue the
master who abandoned them seeking death
at the hands of the man who wields the
red blade known as mountain of corpses